[Music]  i don't want to be like them  locked in a prison if they forgot that  they're in  what prison yes  i am sensing a lack of focus  you didn't keep in touch with cindy at  all after graduation she hasn't even  crossed my mind in 15 years  i do remember cindy williams she just  vanished  that was the time when that awful drug  went around the school  i can't she could feel it something bad  happened to her  one night we were on merc blizzard dude  [Music]  we got to go back we got to try to  remember what happened to her last night  i swear it happened  [Music]  let's just go i'm supposed to be here  [Music]  [Music]  whatever you do just don't take it i  already took it okay  [Music]  it's gonna happen to me i'll show you  all the possibilities  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you